hi there steve kaufman today i want to
talk about
learning languages via the word of the
day
now there are lots of services that can
send you a word every day or you learn a
word of day and new language
in fact
just today i was at my crossfit session
and there was a fellow there we were
talking about language learning and he
said that he's been on this word of the
day but
he said he has trouble remembering the
word of the day and of course my opinion
is that
you know having this word of the day
program
spit a word out at you every day
there's nothing wrong with it
i mean it's giving you some exposure to
the language it's certainly not a
negative
however
it's extremely inefficient as a way of
learning a language it is really in a
sense next to useless
the reason i say that is and bear in
mind if you like doing that by all means
the number one rule of language learning
is do what you like to do however
uh we need to learn so many words in my
opinion you know we need to learn 10 000
15 000 words uh in most languages
um and even then
a lot of context is beyond our grasp
because we're missing some of the key
words
now at a word a day that's 365 words a
year
except that it's far less than that
because
any list of words
you know if you are able to remember a
quarter of them you're doing very well i
can't i forget most of what i learn most
words that i learn i forget and it's
only because i run into these words
again and again
in my reading and listening
of course a link i've highlighted it now
in yellow and i see it again as a word
that i've encountered before and i
slowly by seeing it in different
contexts
i
learn that word and in fact i learn lots
of words at link because
it's not only the words that i save but
as we know more words we're able to
infer more words so we actually learn
what i call incidentally
more words than we learn deliberately
all from meaningful
content
interesting and meaningful content that
we're reading and listening to
and so a word a day
possibly a hundred words a year
given how quickly we forget what we
learn
maximum i would say a hundred words a
year
um you need ten thousand words
uh that's a lot of years
ten years gets due to
a thousand words
so a hundred years would get you to ten
thousand words so a word a day is
relatively
useless
insofar as languages learning is
concerned in fact any kind of learning
words out of context including in my
opinion
using
spaced repetition systems
is not as effective as massive exposure
to the language through lots of
meaningful listening and reading
otherwise you accumulate this tremendous
list
as they call a deck you know of
flashcards that you spend
if i have an hour a day to spend on
language learning i've got to spend an
hour reviewing my flashcards i don't
have an hour then to spend on listening
and reading so
as you've heard before i think that the
by far the most effective way of
learning a language is to
get through that beginner material
get yourself into interesting authentic
material and spend as much time as
possible listening to it and reading it
and don't be trapped into thinking that
the word a day is doing anything other
than amusing you and before i forget it
reminds me this uh the sort of literacy
uh uh organization in canada
did a deal with a newspaper where they
had this word of the day in english
where they teach people
a new word maybe how to spell it or a
word that would be pushing the
boundaries of their vocabulary one word
a day doesn't do much doesn't do much
not in literacy not in language learning
get into reading and listening whether
it be in a language you're learning or
even in your own language to push the
boundaries of your vocabulary and
comprehension that will give you a base
from which you can start speaking better
thank you for listening bye for now